Alright guys, so in this lecture, I'm going to teach you how I personally use auto-flow trading strategy from A to Z, what I look for and all. Okay. So this is my personal method, the matter that I've taught you before, it works as well, but this is a little bit different how I approach it. Okay. So first of all, as you know me, I like to stick with higher time frames. So first of all, I would go to the 4 hour time frame or daily. Okay.
So let's suppose I'm looking at your USD.
So for auto flow, what I like to do is use your USD,
to be used D and AUD USD because I like to,
you know, combine DXY and these pairs together
to find auto flow trades.
And I'm gonna explain that later in the video.
So if I'm on the four hour timeframe
and the market structure is bullish, right?
only going to look for long positions.
And I want a clear trending market.
I do not want consolidation, something like that.
I want a clear perfect trend.
So what happens is when you are on a four-a-ton frame, you're going to have, so let's say
you have a new break of structure.
So this right here is a new break of structure.
going to be an auto block and for you know when I'm on a higher timeframe and also for the auto
flow strategy I use the auto blocks the last bearish candle before move to the upside or consecutive
bearish candles before move to the upside I have made a video about auto blocks on my youtube you
can go and watch it that type of auto blocks I use for this strategy specifically only okay so
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to patiently wait for price to come back into your
autoblock.
And when that happens, wait, yep.
When that happens, I'm going to drop down to 15 minute timeframe and I'm simply going to look
for market structure shift entry during kills on ours and boom.
That is absolutely it guys.
No need to complicate it.
I will give you examples and it's gonna be clear to you, but let me show you another bearish diagram
So let's assume that you have a bearish trend
and you have
consecutive bullish candles before moved to the downside so you mark that out the body of the candle, okay?
You're gonna watch you have to watch that video on YouTube
And then you're gonna know what I'm talking about so when price comes back
Right you drop down to 15 minute
you look for market structure shift okay and once you have like market
structure shift you take your entry from that last bullish candle that is going
to be here the body of the candle okay or you could use consecutive bullish
candles so I will give you an examples I'll give you a couple of examples and it's
going to be clear what I'm talking about. So the very first rule is identify high
timeframe market structure. Price action has to be in a solid trending position.
Okay. It has to trend. Okay. It does not need to be console dating. No, we do
not want that. Because when price is console dating, that is the condition where
there's gonna be a lot of liquidy sweeps. So even though your buys or your prediction
about the trend is accurate, it's gonna stop you out most of the time. So just see guys,
forics is the game of patience. If a guy is good with his psychology and it has some sort
of patience, he's gonna just kill these markets. Whereas a person who has like the best
in the world but his psychology is shit. He's gonna lose money. Trust me. Okay?
Because when I studied ICT back in like 2018 and 17, I was a student and
I knew what I was doing but my psychology was so bad guys like I
Literally would over risk revenge trade and all so don't do that. Okay?
I'm just saying these things because so you don't have to go through those things again
So in a solid training position, we have that perfect weight for
Be a break of structure and also
let me point this out
the
Autoblog that is right here right it could be here as well too and it means any
Autoblog above the 0.5 level, okay?
You just have to look for confirmation and we so let's say there is a bullish
this is, yeah, if there is a bullish candle right here,
something around here, right?
You wait for price to come back here.
Let me do that.
Okay, so you wait for price to come back
and do the auto block, look for market structure shift.
And if it gives you market structure shift
or confirmation entry, take that trade, okay?
Simple as that.
And what I sometimes like is when I'm on the four
all the time frame, right?
And there's auto block here.
I wanna see some sort of little bit of consolidation here,
guys.
Like, if you have the patience to look for this, right?
And then price goes back into your POI,
look for confirmation entry and boom.
Okay.
So, yeah, guys, let me give you guys a couple of examples.
And that is going to be clear for you.